[Music]
welcome everybody uh to the Pete homes
show a special Pete home show my my
parents are here right there in the
second row hello
parents your my dad is trying to signal
to you go ahead to to the camera that
the Red Sox are number
one his his main agenda in being here is
to let the world know that he thinks the
Red Soxs are number one so that's if you
can see my brother that's a special
homes brother face the the shepherding
of my parents is
not it is not easy they're delightful
people but together difficult difficult
uh so I'm glad you guys could be here of
course they they named me that's a
pretty big
deal uh they they named me Peter but I
go by Pete uh who has the
time it's a big Time Saver and and Pete
I I feel like that's a friendly Choice
it's a friendly name here's something
you'll never hear who stabbed you
Pete no get out of here
Derek you're a liar Derek I'm a Pete
every morning I wake up and I remember
I'm a Pete and then I act like a Pete
friendly Pete if your name is Ms you
wake up every morning and act like a Ms
like well I'm a months time to go beat
up some
seymor and if you're a Seymour you're
like well time to go mix up some
vaccines before all them mces get here
and break my
beakers that's what I'm saying you got
to be careful with the name if you name
your kid Dusty it's never like hey
Dusty which Rolex would you like to wear
to the dinner with the Prime
Minister it's always like hey Dusty uh
there's a bunch of tampons jammed into
the hand dryer in the girls restroom
could you work your magic
dust be careful that's the scariest part
to me the scariest part of having kids
is naming them I mean I get stressed out
just naming my my video game
characters sitting at home clammy hands
panic attack just like ah he's an elf
Mage uh it's got spells of invisibility
and
fire Gary
I imagine naming an actual person it's
terrifying some of my friends had kids
when they were 23 and Nam them as you
want to
do a 23-year-old should not be making
those decisions when I was 23 I was
religious and in a weird wine
phas I just started drinking and needed
something
light if I had had kids back then I
would have been like these are my boys
Nehemiah and Beringer white zendel
holes say hello
boys I think one of the reasons it's so
hard to name kids is that names
constantly go in and out of style when's
the last time you met a tween named
Eustace never but I promise you Eustace
used to be a sexy night a couple of guys
swapping stories around the wash basin
would be like what'd you do last night
oh last night was crazy I snuck from my
bed chamber and crossed The Dewy fields
to the Abode of my lover and I straight
up plowed
Eustace I was going to say fingered but
my parents are
here
[Applause]
I'm just not going to look over there
for a little
bit what I'm saying is no name is uh
safe from going out of style think about
it they're probably a bunch of Bryant
here it could happen to briyan I'm
serious you think mortimers saw it
coming show me a Mortimer under the age
of 80 and I'll show you a hipster who
changed his
name that's why you want it's hard to
follow fingering
as a note for the show close on the
fingering
Joel I've now said it three times I
think that's why you should give your
kid a flexible name this is true I think
you should give your guy a flexible name
if you have a boy like William that's
the perfect guy name because when you're
little you can be Billy everybody likes
little Billy Billy shares and has a
healthy interest in sports and
digging
and puberty hits you want to seem more
like a man all of a sudden your will
same name Will confusing semester abroad
will with one
L hope you got condoms in that backpack
L recently divorced and getting back out
there hey I'm Bill
perfect I have a feeling tonight's going
to be a good night will I am come on
don't don't back away from that that is
a good joke
[Applause]
[Music]
love